have no regrets if you are afraid of
starting something new if you are
thinking about quitting your business if
you're having a really hard time with
something having a really hard time
making a decision a framework that might
help you is fast forward your life to
when you're 80 years old and think back
am I gonna regret not doing this am I
gonna regret not having bet on myself
and taking that chance if you look at
people who are on their deathbed and you
look at you know what they wish they
could have changed on their lives the
most common answer that comes back is I
regret that I didn't take more chances
don't be that person
bet on yourself take your chances now
while you can still take your shot one
of my favorite stories is about the
founder of Amazon Jeff Bezos when he was
30 years old he was the youngest ever
vice president at his company it was an
investment banking company he was making
a six-figure salary and he saw the
growth of the internet and he said I'm
gonna do this crazy thing and start this
business on the Internet I'm gonna quit
my job my high paying job move my wife
to Seattle to start all over again start
from scratch with nothing and start this
Internet company when at the time people
didn't know about two-inches like what
what are you doing Jeff look what the
heck are you doing you what you are on
the fast track man you're 30 years old
the youngest ever vice president at this
company you're making six-figure salary
why would you throw it all away to start
this thing on the what's the internet
are you kidding me and what helped him
make that difficult decision was that he
didn't want to live his life with regret
here's one of my favorite quotes from
him as he was explaining this decision
that he had to go through so I wanted to
project myself forward to age 80 and say
okay now I'm looking back on my life I
want to have minimized the number of
regrets I have
and you know what I knew that when I was
80 I was not going to regret having
tried this I was not gonna regret having
wanted you know trying to participate in
this thing called the Internet that I
thought was gonna be a really big deal I
knew that if I failed
I wouldn't regret that but I knew the
one thing I might regret is not ever
having tried and I knew that that would
haunt me every day so have no regrets
bet on yourself
take your shot while you still can and
believe you guys liked this video let me
know what your shot is let me know how
you're betting on yourself and you're
not living with regrets leave a comment
below you like the video give it a
thumbs up and click on my face and
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon